[ __ ] you dear I'm really you know you
you jiggle a lot which is something I
appreciate hello how do you t take bad
item get popularity I mean all right
I'll do it
you item good like bad like no like
you're still gonna die are you lost one
leg it's not an item you just cut off my
leg ow
I can't sprint up [ __ ] you dude
say I'm a dick I'm a dick I'm a dick
baby I'm a big ol dick please can I have
my leg back or did you vote for me why
did you guys give me heels while
sprinting you sometimes triple in volume
I can't
Prince I have one leg well I am [ __ ]
up Archie [ __ ] he [ __ ] hey I got
bloody grimy hands and only one leg of
the door god damn it oh we've gotta go
well Oh God probably you know if I dive
and at least it would be merciful on me
because I don't have a [ __ ] butt